today those who've done the least to
cause
this problem
are being the hardest hit
ultimately all of us will feel the
impact some of which are now unavoidable
my world is melting you think you have
control we actually have no control i'm
absolutely terrified
to bring a child to this world
is this how our story is due to end
a tale of the smartest species doomed by
that all-too-human characteristic
of failing to see the bigger picture in
pursuit of short-term goals
perhaps the fact that the people most
affected by climate change are no longer
some imagined future generation but
young people alive today
perhaps that will give us the impetus we
need
to rewrite our story
to turn this tragedy
into a triumph
we are after all the greatest problem
solvers to have ever existed on earth
we now understand this problem
we know how to stop the number rising
and put it in reverse
we must have carbon emissions
it's halt them this decade
we must recapture billions of tons of
carbon from the air
we must fix our sites on keeping one and
a half degrees within reach
a new industrial revolution
powered by millions of sustainable
innovations
is
essential and is indeed already
beginning
we will all share
in the benefits
affordable clean energy
healthy air
and enough food to sustain us all
nature is a key ally
whenever we restore the wild
it will recapture carbon and help us
bring back balance to our planet
and as we work to build a better world
we must acknowledge
no nation has completed its development
because no advanced nation is yet
sustainable
[Music]
all have a journey still to compete
so that all nations have a good standard
of living and a modest footprint
we're going to have to learn
together
how to achieve this
ensuring none are left behind
we must use this opportunity to create a
more equal world
and our motivation should not be fear
but hope
can we fix climate
problem in one generation my answer
would be
yes
we have to
we need to not just to talk about
what we can do but
to do
what we can this is a challenge that we
should try to solve in a quick way with
the long term vision
it comes down to this
the people alive now
are the generation to come
we'll look at this conference and
consider one thing
did that number stop rising and start to
drop as a result of commitments made
here
there's every reason to believe that the
answer can be yes
if working apart
we are force powerful enough to
destabilize our planet
surely
working together we are powerful enough
to save it
[Music]
in my lifetime
i've witnessed a terrible decline
in yours
you could and should witness a wonderful
recovery that desperate hope ladies and
gentlemen
delicates
excellency
is why the world is looking to you
and why you
are here